[Music]
I welcome to this big breaking news
edition of Hannity live from Miami hello
Miami great all right we begin tonight a
Fox News Alert tonight the witch-hunt
the Schumer ship sham show it is
thankfully for the sake of the country
over the United States Senate they
officially voted to deny the Democrats
latest witness stunt and the final vote
to acquit the president is now
inevitable will take place now we expect
4:00 p.m. Wednesday afternoon the
country can now hopefully finally move
on from this fact free partisan and
Pietschmann sham that will go down in
history as one of the biggest and single
most embarrassing Democratic blunders of
all time
now this three-year long never-ending
temper tantrum
it will be over Wednesday the damage to
the country as of tonight incalculable
the exact same people those people that
lied Russia Russia Russia impeach
impeach collusion collusion three years
of this those that advance their
conspiracy theories almost dailies those
that totally ignored what was the
biggest single abuse of power corruption
scandal in history those who ignored the
dirty dossier premeditated fraud on a
FISA Court to deny one American his
civil liberties his constitutional
rights those that were spying on a
presidential candidate illegally his
transition team deep into the trump
presidency those same people and of
course their allies in the media mob
they failed at what was the latest coup
attempt now all while they have not
lifted a single finger at all
to help you we the American people they
didn't create a single job they didn't
make us any more safe or secure or
prosperous they have dragged this out of
being their usual immature selves
clearly their hatred of President Trump
now surpasses their desire to do
anything for the American people as
evidenced by the last three years this
is actually a sad
in a very dangerous chapter we are
closing in this country's history
earlier today Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell he secured the votes to
block further witnesses and prevent
further distraction in other words they
didn't take on what was the sole
constitutional role of the House to
impeach by the way now that the end is
in sight it cannot be soon enough after
key GOP senators Lamar Alexander Lisa
Murkowski announced their opposition to
caving to the Democrats latest
last-minute Hail Mary for what more
witnesses we had an opinion witnesses
hearsay witnesses the only one fact
witness says what did the president want
nothing no quid or pro or quo like Joe
they did exactly what the United States
Constitution as professor Dershowitz
rightly pointed out required of them
Senator Murkowski released a statement
very powerful reading quote the house
chose to send articles of impeachment
that are rushed and flawed I carefully
considered the need for additional
witnesses and documents to cure the
shortcomings of its process but
ultimately decided that I will vote
against considering motions to subpoena
and last night senator Lamar Alexander
Tweedy
if this shallow hurried wholly partisan
impeachment were to succeed it would rip
the country apart pouring gasoline on
the fire of cultural divisions that
already exist
it would create the weapon of Perpetual
impeachment to be used against future
presidents whenever the House of
Representatives is on of a different
political party senators thank you thank
you for standing for the American people
thank you for standing for truth for
facts for fairness thank you for
standing against what is a rage fueled
partisan witch hunt thank you for
standing for our Constitution any effort
to extend this charade any longer is not
only a waste of time it puts a further
divide in this country